Sava what do we know good afternoon Jane
while the incident has been described as
a deeply distressing and tragic by
Staffordshire police this is of course
after they have confirmed that two young
children died yesterday in
Stoke-on-Trent an 11 year old boy and a
seven-year-old girl now this all came
about yesterday afternoon after police
were called to a car wash about half
past two in the afternoon in The Stoke
area that they had received reports that
a man in his 40s had been stabbed the
man in question was taken to hospital
and was subsequently released now it was
shortly afterwards that police went to a
house nearby where they arrested a 49
year old woman in connection to the
stabbing now it was while they were
there that they found two young children
unresponsive they said with serious
injuries now the police have also said
that despite the efforts of paramedics
at the scene unfortunately the two young
people had died now the relationship
between the two young people and the
woman in question is unclear but what we
do know according to police is that they
the children were known to the woman now
the 49 year old individual has since
been arrested by the police on suspicion
of murder and is currently in police
custody now in a statement from the
police chief or detective Chief
Inspector Cheryl Hanan has said the
following our faults are very much with
the family and friends of the children I
cannot imagine the pain and shock they
are feeling our priority was to inform
the family before confirming the ages of
the children they are currently being
supported by specially trained officers
the woman arrested is known to the
children we don't believe there to be
any wider threats to the public at this
time now police are calling on people
who were at Flack Street or Campbell
Road in The Stoke area between 1 30 to 2
30 P.M to come forwards with any
information that they may have whether
that's from you know an eyewitness
account CCTV dash cam footage anything
of the sort that could help with this
investigation